this is the facebook logo this is a pile
of tobacco why
because at the recent facebook hearings
we've heard a lot of this
facebook is just like big tobacco
pushing a product that they know is
harmful to the health of young people
facebook has taken big tobacco's
playbook the tobacco industry big
tobacco big tobacco all right so you get
it members of congress really like this
comparison especially around the impacts
and harms of social media on kids and if
you look back at the hearings of the
1990s where the chief executives of the
biggest tobacco companies testified you
can see why it's a handy comparison but
as i'll explain an imperfect one do you
believe nicotine is not addictive
i believe nicodemus is not addictive yet
congressman
cigarettes and nicotine clearly do not
meet the classic definitions of
addiction i don't believe that nicotine
or our products are addictive i believe
nicotine is not addictive
and here we are more than 25 years later
we certainly do not want our products to
be addictive so i i disagree with
calling our product addictive i also
think that's not how we build products
in our recent wall street journal
facebook file series my colleagues
revealed internal company documents that
show that the company knows its products
cause harm including to kids
okay
back to tobacco now while it's a
convenient analogy
in some ways it goes up in smoke
for one the tobacco companies spent
decades concealing their research lying
and covering up what they knew
and even more important social media
does not cause lung cancer the truth is
that cigarettes are the single most
dangerous consumer product ever sold
that's former democratic congressman
henry waxman he led the big tobacco
hearings in the 1990s
this is him now
so tobacco and social media
what do you make of this comparison
there's nothing good about tobacco it's
the only legal product we have
that we know that
kills admit and makes people sick
and has no redeeming value
social media has pluses and some big
minuses
facebook spokesman joe osborne said in a
statement it's an absurd comparison
social media helps people connect and
small businesses thrive but looking at
how lawmakers came up with regulation
for this box may give us some clues
about how they might handle this box
but to do that we have to look at the
similarities between the two the first
we can call hooking for profit the more
addicted you are to smoking the more
money tobacco companies make the more
time you spend scrolling facebook or
instagram and thus consuming ads the
more money facebook makes
in the 1990s the debacle companies
denied adjusting nicotine levels to
encourage addiction the claim that
philip morris secretly adds nicotine
during the manufacturing process to keep
smokers addicted is false
and here we are in 2021 but i want to
drill down on this addictive element but
isn't part of your business model
to have more eyeballs for a longer
amount of time
engaged
using your services
respectfully senator that's not that's
not actually how we build our products
then there's the not sharing of research
you're the chief executive officer you
what reason could you not give us this
research if it uh if it's been conducted
i have i have no problem giving you any
material we have if it's not in some way
involved in uh in active litigation at
this time and here we are today will you
disclose all of the reports all the
findings will you commit to full
disclosure yeah i know that we have
released a number of the reports and we
are looking to find ways to release more
of this research
i want to be clear that this research is
not a bombshell it's not causal research
this research is a bombshell now again
the tobacco companies hid years of
scientific evidence of health impacts of
their product in facebook's case the
company is in early days of
understanding the impacts of its digital
tools and it has already shared some
information and that's perhaps the
biggest link being made between big
tobacco and facebook hooking the kids
early though i guess you could say that
of other companies
like junk food
maybe we should have done this whole
video about facebook and junk food the
most famous tobacco targeting to kids
american medical association found that
91 percent of the children
three through six could match joe with a
camel cigarette
which means mr johnson that joe camel
was as well known as mickey mouse
do you still maintain that joe camel
cartoons are not targeted towards
children
um
congressman signer when
it's a simple question mr johnson do you
contend you to contend that it's not
targeted towards children
clearly and absolutely but i can mr
johnson
the facebook documents published by the
wall street journal show that the
company has been thinking of more ways
to engage children one slide reads
leverage play dates to increase growth
slash retention in our testimony to
congress francis haugen the facebook
whistleblower who gathered the documents
that informed the journal series made
her perspective clear they have to make
sure that that the next generation is
just as engaged with instagram as the
current one
um and the way they'll do that is by
making sure that children
establish habits before they have good
self-regulation by hooking kids by
hooking kids
the facebook spokesman said companies
that operate in a highly competitive
space including the wall street journal
make efforts to appeal to younger
generations
since those big tobacco hearings in the
90s we've seen regulation and
settlements that have limited the use
and marketing of these especially to
kids
the master settlement agreement of 1998
banned advertising targeted at those
younger than 18 and banned the use of
cartoons like joe camel
ultimately in 2009 the fda was given the
right to regulate tobacco products
including the levels of nicotine a very
similar set of parallel regulations have
to be put on the books in order to
protect
children from
instagram from social media in the same
way that our nation put laws on the
books to protect children against big
tobacco that's democratic senator ed
markey he has drafted the kids internet
design and safety act or the kids act it
aims to create new protections for users
under 16. they get to the heart of
what's addicting about social media we
have to ban
push notification we have to ban auto
play
we have to make sure that the algorithms
uh can't be set so that it's
deliberately playing games with the
minds of children in our country uh up
to the age of 16. then there's the
children's online privacy protection act
or kappa 2.0 which is also backed by
marky and has gained bipartisan support
it would extend the current privacy
protections to 13 through 15 year olds
ban targeted advertising to kids and
more beyond protecting the children
others argue for regulating social media
content algorithms
and adjusting section 230 the law that
shields online platforms from being
liable for harmful content posted on
their sites but even if congress agrees
on all that it will still have to
contend with lobbyists as it did with
big tobacco facebook and other social
media companies they can buy just about
every lobbyist in washington dc
but when the subject of children
of teenagers
is raised
they're in a position which is
indefensible the facebook spokesman said
that the company is in support of
regulation it's time for congress to act
this all now sits with the lawmakers and
if tobacco regulation is our guide
it could be with them for a long time
i reek of tobacco